[Musik]
ich habe den vatikan zum ersten mal am 9
märz 1993 betreten was für ein
nervenkitzel ein großer nervenkitzel
denn ich habe zwar immer meine kunden
besucht auch institutionelle kunden aber
für einen katholiken ist dass sie etwas
besonderes etwas sehr aufregendes
[Musik]
alle meine freunde wussten dass sich
seit vielen jahren als manager tätig war
und wenn sie mich sahen nannten sie mich
immer den bankier gottes
[Musik]
das war natürlich ein geistreicher
scherz für den ich heute leider auch
wirklich brutale weise bezahlen muss tja
da bin ich nun
[Musik]
mea culpa
korruptionen im vatikan
[Musik]
kann ich es abnehmen danke
es ist so real denn gestern bis zwei
minuten nach sechs hatte ich das gefühl
ein freund des papstes zu sein ein
treuer gefolgsmann des papstes und dann
steht der papst hier und sagt mir dass
er mir nicht mehr vertraut
wahrscheinlich konnte der papst nicht
ahnen was für skandale eine untersuchung
über den erwerb eines großen gebäudes im
zentrum londons auslösen könnte es
handelt sich um den schwersten finanz
kanal der letzten 30 jahre im vatikan
es ist eine art vatikan gate bei dem
franziskus beschlossen hat zumindest
scheinbar niemandem gegenüber
rechenschaft abzulegen
es ist ein skandal sie haben dinge getan
die nicht anständig waren
bolatti no das hat das publikum so sido
ich lese jeden tag das buletten dass der
heilige stuhl auf seiner website
veröffentlicht anfang oktober 2009 10
standort in drei zeilen ganz lapidar
dass die vatikanische gendarmerie eine
reihe von durchsuchungen im büro des
staatssekretariats durchgeführt hat da
es sich um das büro handelt das den
papst am nächsten steht konnten wir
erkennen dass eine erschütternde
untersuchung begonnen hatte und dass
eine solche aktion im vatikan
offensichtlich nicht ohne die billigung
und genehmigung von papst franziskus
beschlossen werden konnte
es war der interne prüfer der sagte dass
hier etwas schlimmes vorlag
kam zu mir und ich fragte ihn ob er sich
sicher sei er zeigte mir die zahlen und
fragte mich was er tun solle
dafür ist die vatikanische justiz
zuständig g und melde es den pro motor
der justiz
der justiz bat mich um die erlaubnis für
die durchsuchungen es bestand der
verdacht der korruption und in diesen
fällen sagte er müsse er dieses büro
durchsuchen dieses büro also
unterschrieb ich die genehmigung
[Musik]
was wir ihnen erzählen werden ist eine
geschichte die sich im operativen herzen
des vatikans ab spielt in dem dem papst
am nächsten stehenden ministerium dem
staatssekretariat das bis in die schweiz
hinein reicht um diese komplizierte
geschichte verständlicher zu gestalten
haben wir beschlossen einige szenen mit
schauspielern nachzustellen im
mittelpunkt der ermittlungen steht eine
handvoll finanziers und hochrangiger
privaten wie von der vatikanischen
justiz verdächtigt werden einen
kriminellen plan zur plünderung der
vatikanischen staatskasse ausgeheckt zu
haben
[Musik]
ich habe einen anruf vom
staatssekretariat erhalten monsignore
angelo betta wollte mit mir sprechen um
mich mit einer bestimmten aufgabe zu
betrauen
er sagte mir hören sie ich habe einen
sehr guten freund der die rechte an
einem ölfeld in angola besetzt damals
war die rede vom größten jemals in
afrika entdeckten öl fällt etwa 180.000
barrel pro tag etwas riesiges
förderungen für 25 jahre
wenn sie baten mich um eine
stellungnahme für mich war das ein
absolutes novum denn ich war
ausschließlich im finanzbereich tätig
und wer wir haben enrico calesso in
lugano getroffen der treuhänder ist eine
zentrale figur in dieser untersuchung
die seit monaten das interesse der
großen nationalen zeitungen auf sich
zieht und wieder einmal wirft sie ein
schlechtes licht auf den tessiner
finanzplatz gras so ist seit über 20
jahren externer fondsmanager des
staatssekretariats im auftrag mehrerer
banken zuletzt für die credit suisse im
jahr 2014 zog er von rom nach lugano um
seine eigene treuhandgesellschaft so
schnell zu eröffnen der ehemalige banker
hat sich bereit erklärt uns in einem
ausführlichen interview seine sicht der
dinge zu schildern
das ist eine treuhand urkunde
die geschichte begann im jahr 2013 als
monsignore bio ihn wegen einer
investition im ölsektor kontaktierte
valuta glaube sie mussten den wert
dieses geschäfts schätzen aber war eine
investition in ethisch vertretbar
das ist eine gute frage aber wenn eine
institution einen investitions vorschlag
hat gehe ich davon aus dass dieser
aspekt von ihrer seite aus bereits
geprüft und berücksichtigt worden ist
wie viel hat der vatikan investieren
sollen sie sprachen von 200 millionen
dollar monsignore angelo betta der
schöpfer dieser investition bekleidete
damals das amt des stellvertreters für
allgemeine angelegenheiten das heißt des
stellvertreters des leiters des
staatssekretariats kardinal parolin er
war der dritte in der hierarchie des
vatikans
[Musik]
das staatssekretariat verfügt über eine
staatskasse von 650 millionen euro die
sich zu einem drittel aus einem fonds
dem sogenannten paul dem sechsten fonds
und zu zwei dritteln aus einem fond des
petrus dienstes speist
der peterspfennig der etwa 400 millionen
euro wert ist stand stattdessen aus
allen almosen die dem papst von den
gläubigen aus aller welt direkt
gespendet werden
das staatssekretariat sollte das geld
aus dem peterspfennig für die
unterstützung der ärmsten verwenden auch
für die verwaltung der weltkirche
der peterspfennig ist quasi sowie eine
riesige almosen büchse in einer kirche
er ist im grunde eine art geldautomat
und der ist wichtig ihnen
steht dadurch stets frisches geld zur
verfügung das sie investieren können und
das nicht von vornherein einer kontrolle
durch den eu er unterliegt
kardinal bachelor hat testamentarisch
verfügt dass ein teil der gelder aus dem
peterspfennig der aus den spenden der
gläubigen an den papst stand und zur
unterstützung der kirche und der ärmsten
der armen bestimmt ist in eine ölquelle
in angola investiert werden soll
die päpstlichen richter ist dies das
erste verbrechen das ihnen vorgeworfen
wird die zweckentfremdung von geldern
die für wohltätige zwecke bestimmt waren
für eine spektakuläre anlage eine
anschuldigung die auch enrico krassow
betraf wieder dem staatssekretariat
geholfen haben soll die wahre herkunft
des geldes zu verschleiern indem er sich
die zu investierende summe bei den
banken geliehen und das geld aus dem
peterspfennig verpfändet hat er wolle
dies am pietro
mit ihrem source war das geld das für
wohltätige zwecke verwendet werden
sollte das war das geld aus dem petrus
pfennig
aber sie haben es den vermögensverwalter
nicht gesagt sie haben uns nicht gesagt
dass die gelder für wohltätige zwecke
sind ich weiß nicht ob den banken gesagt
wurde dass sie mit dem geld das sie
bekamen vorsichtig umgehen sollten dass
es nur für wohltätige zwecke verwaltet
werden durfte nein denn sonst hätten die
banken keine operation durchgeführt aber
ich würde gerne wissen warum stellen sie
mir diese frage
mit dem auftrag den er erhalten hatte
musste enrico klasse das geschäft auf
machbarkeit zu überprüfen
weil er aber keine erfahrung im öl
sektor hatte suchte er nach einem
experten
[Musik]
ich sagte ihm eure exzellenz meine
erfahrung ist finanzieller natur ich
kann ihnen natürlich helfen aber was den
technischen teil angeht muss ich ihnen
sagen dass ich mich mit meiner bank in
verbindung setzen werde er sagte ja ja
bleiben sie ganz ruhig verhalten sie
sich sehr diskret wir müssen es nicht
tun wenn es machbar ist wenn es
interessant ist und alle kriterien
erfüllt sind werden wir es machen
ansonsten nicht
[Musik]
nun ich wies darauf hin dass sich zu der
bank gehen würde mit der ich arbeite und
so weiter und die credit suisse riet mir
nach london zu gehen wo ich mit der
mensch ohne gruppe bekannt gemacht wurde
die experten auf dem gebiet
zu diesem zeitpunkt tauchte im vatikan
eine neue mysteriöse figur auf raffael
im in führung ein internationaler
finanziell italienischer abstammung der
in london mailand und luxemburg tätig
war
[Musik]
sie haben raffaele menschen zum ersten
mal in london getroffen was war ihr
eindruck von ihm
[Musik]
erschien ein experte zu sein er erzählte
mir dass er aus einer zerrütteten
familie stammt sein vater hatte einige
schwierigkeiten
nach london und gründete von dort aus
sein unternehmen er sagte er habe ein
enges verhältnis mit der emi gruppe die
bank habe mit ihm in london geschäfte
gemacht er meinte also wenn derjenige
der ihn mir vorgestellt hat ihm vertraut
müsste ich mir keine sorgen machen
dem kardinal vorgestellt
das habe ich
nachdem sie die zustimmung von kardinal
angelo betta erhalten hatten machten
sich raffaele wenn sie ohne und enrico
klasse an die arbeit um die technische
und finanzielle machbarkeit der
investition zu prüfen in der
zwischenzeit wurden die 200 millionen
die für die investition vorgesehen waren
umgehend auf einen fonds im besitz von
raffaele menschen übertragen doch nach
einem jahr der studien und bewertungen
gaben die beiden finanziers ein
negatives urteil und räten von dem
geschäft ab
machu picchu nahm es zur kenntnis
breitete die arme aus wie es üblich ist
und rührte keinen finger als wollte er
sagen mal sehen machen wir es und damit
war alles zu ende denn die operation
wurde nicht fortgeführt
[Musik]
dem staatssekretariat herrscht heute
große unruhe es ist der siebte juni 2013
und soeben ist ein bericht aus lugano
eingetroffen der einen dunklen schatten
auf die figur von raffaele menschen
wirft
sie es handelt sich um einen artikel aus
der wochenzeitung il mondo den die
credit suisse an den schatzmeister des
sekretariats fabrizio de la bastille und
an monsignore palast die rechte hand von
erzbischof angelo vecchio geschickt hat
in dem artikel steht dass einige
italienische abgeordnete nach dem
versuch des finanziers die banca
popolare di milano zu übernehmen
parlamentarische anfragen gestellt haben
um sich über die undurchsichtigkeit der
finanzströme seines unternehmens und
über die schwierigkeit die herkunft
seiner finanziellen mittel zu
rechtfertigen zu beschweren
[Musik]
er hertha sie
in ein bericht der ernst genommen werden
muss ist es möglich dass niemand im
sekretariat diesen verdachtsfällen
nachgegangen ist ich wollte wissen wie
sie zum fall des vatikans stehen
kein kommentar auch von monsignore per
laska die gerichtsdokumente zeigen
jedoch dass sich die beziehung zwischen
dem staatssekretariat und raffaele
menschen trotz dieser dunklen schatten
sogar noch verstärkt hat
aber der kontakt zwischen raffaele
mensch ohne und dem staatssekretariat
gehalten
ja es wurde ein kontakt hergestellt und
damit die möglichkeit das vertrauen des
kunden zu gewinnen und
das hat er geschafft
er schlug eine weitere investition vor
und sie stimmten zu
wir schreiben den juli 2014 ein
zentraler moment in dieser geschichte
als das staatssekretariat beschließt die
idee in die ölquelle in angola zu
investieren endgültig aufzugeben und
sein interesse auf ein anderes
unternehmen zu richten
raphaela schlug vor ein gebäude in
london zu kaufen das alte kaufhaus
harrods dass einer seiner firmen gehört
das projekt wurde sofort von fabrizio
tiger bassey und monsignore per laster
befürwortet
[Musik]
mode kauf des gebäudes wurde als eine
sehr günstige investition dargestellt
logik war dass sie für etwas bezahlten
das weit unter seinem marktwert lag
30 bis 40 prozent unter dem was sie mit
dem verkauf oder sogar mit der
renovierung hätten erzielen können weil
es eine art baugenehmigung gab die die
erhöhung und den bau erlaubte es würde
eine große immobilieninvestition werden
es ist ein wunderschönes gebäude das
alte kaufhaus harrods in london eintraf
set wie man es nennt
und so einigen sich die parteien darauf
wie die 200 millionen dollar investiert
werden sollen wie das staatssekretariat
bereits oder viele menschen anvertraut
hatte und die in seinen athena
investmentformen geflossen waren
100 millionen dollar wurden für den kauf
von 45 prozent der anteile an dem
londoner gebäude bereitgestellt das
dementi ohne fonds gehört
der rest wurde in finanzinstrumente
desselben athener fonds investiert
sie waren nicht eigentümer des gebäudes
sondern besitzer von fondsanteilen die
vereinbarungen sehen vor dass die
anderen liquiden mittel in vereinbarten
finanzinstrumenten angelegt werden
sollten aber
schon er hatte als vermögensverwalter
gehandelt und sie so eingesetzt wie er
es eben tat
der vatikan war also nicht der direkte
eigentümer des gebäudes sondern nur
besitzer von fondsanteilen den richtern
zufolge sorgte millionen auch für einen
großen verlust für den heiligen stuhl in
dem er die verbleibenden 100 millionen
in finanzinstrumente von unternehmen die
mit ihm verbunden sind oder auf jeden
fall in spekulative und illiquide
finanzinstrumente investiert
[Musik]
man darf nicht vergessen dass es an den
finanzmärkten nach 2008 immer weiter
nach oben ging
wenn der liquiditäts anteil also ich
will nicht sagen umsichtig aber
gewissenhaft verwaltet worden wäre wären
die erträge höchstwahrscheinlich höher
gewesen als die verwaltungsgebühren
stattdessen schrieb der athena ford
tiefrote zahlen und verbrannte in fünf
jahren 18 millionen euro wie die
berechnungen der päpstlichen justiz
zeigen aber nicht nur das für die
durchführung dieser operationen die zu
dem wirtschaftlichen desaster führte
hätte der fonds von raffaele mission dem
staatssekretariat weitere 18 millionen
euro an provisionen in rechnung gestellt
mission
guten morgen ich suche muss der mensch
ohne er ist nicht hier um wie viel uhr
kommt er wieder er kommt nicht er ist
nicht hier aber wohnt er hier
wir befinden uns also wieder einmal im
herzen der schweiz in chile rina nur
einen steinwurf von sankt moritz
entfernt hier ist der finanziell
offiziell gemeldet aber wir treffen noch
einen seiner bediensteten an keine spur
von ihm
[Musik]
nein nein er war in den letzten monaten
wegen des corona virus da aber
normalerweise wohnt er nicht hier
[Musik]
ist bekannt dass er in chile riener
wohnhaft war
iva de cuisine dicke so steht es in den
unterlagen der staatsanwaltschaft der
finanzier hat außerdem große interessen
in der schweiz nicht nur weil einige
seiner unternehmen dort ansässig sind
sondern auch weil er miteigentümer des
legendären hotel pallas in sankt moritz
ist wir hätten also gerne seine seite
der geschichte erfahren zumal die
ermittler mensch ohne selbst als die
person bezeichnen die am meisten von den
londoner missgeschick des heiligen
stuhls profitiert hätte
am telefon erreichen wir seine
haushälterin
[Musik]
erklären sie ihm dass es besser wäre
wenn er mir ein interview gibt
wenn er sich dafür zur verfügung stellt
kann er mir sagen wie seine position ist
man sich herausgestellt hat dass er
viele millionen abgezweigt hat
diese summen entziehen sich
normalsterblichen das ist die
schwierigkeit die ich oft habe wenn ich
sie nenne und den lesern davon erzähle
anhand der wege die dieses geld genommen
hat können wir ableiten wie sie eher
nicht nur der wille der spender sondern
auch der wille des papstes verraten
wurde wir können also davon ausgehen
dass es das ziel des papstes ist das
geld wieder zu erlangen und vor allem
die schuldigen innerhalb des heiligen
stuhls zu bestrafen
es war im mai 2018 als etwas bizarres
geschah der papst erhob erzbischof
angelo betta in den rang eines kardinals
und ernannte ihn zum präfekten der
kongregation für die selig- und
heiligsprechungen es mag wie eine
beförderung erscheinen aber in
wirklichkeit das sagen viele leute im
vatikan war der einzige zweck dieser
geste angelo betta von der leitung des
staatssekretariats zu entfernen
im vatikan herrschte bereits eine
wachsende verlegenheit über die
situation die durch diese verlustreiche
investition entstanden war und man war
sich nicht einig darüber was zu tun sei
[Musik]
hallo leila sind sie stadtrat willi ohne
anwalt von kardinal bet you
nun ich rufe sie an weil ich sie um eine
stellungnahme oder ein interview bitten
wollte wir hätten gerne von der
betroffenen person gewusst warum sie
ausgerechnet das geld das dem papst von
den gläubigen angeboten wurde in ein so
obskures und spekulatives geschäft
investieren doch seine eminenz lehnte
jeden kommentar ab
will er nichts dazu sagen
eine sache die sie tun sollten und das
habe ich schon im februar 2017 gesagt
ist die rückerstattung zu bekommen eine
lösung zu finden aber vor allem eine
bewertung der immobilie vorzunehmen
mit wem haben sie gesprochen ich habe an
monsignore per laster und herrn taraba
sie geschrieben und was haben sie
geantwortet sie haben nicht geantwortet
tatsächlich beschlossen die leiter des
sekretariats erst im november 2008 10
nach dem abgang von kardinal vecchio den
fonds von raffaele millionen zu
verlassen allerdings mit dem ziel das
gesamte gebäude in london zu kaufen an
dem sie bereits 45 prozent der anteile
besaß sie konnten sich jedoch nicht mit
dem finanzier einigen
und in diesem moment betritt ein neuer
aktie ebenfalls aus london die bühne
unseres rollenspiels ein weiterer makler
mit italienischen wurzeln
sie wurde gebeten ein problem zu lösen
das das staatssekretariat zu dieser zeit
hatte es war ein ziemlich dringendes
problem
es ging darum einen weg zu finden der es
dem staatssekretariat ermöglichte das
eigentum an der immobilie wieder zu
erlangen
sie identifizierte sich damit aus
vielerlei konten abgesehen von seinen
eigenen beruflichen fähigkeiten kannte
er vor allem herren missionen gut
sie wurde als lösung präsentiert um aus
dem deal mit menschen heraus zu kommen
er sagte ter abassi dass er derjenige
sei der mensch ohne davon überzeugen
könne das gebäude aufzugeben
nun er sagte dass mensch ohne den er
sehr gut kannte wegen der
geschäftsbeziehungen die sie hatten und
der manchmal mit seinen firmen
finanzierte nicht nein sagen konnte ich
war jedoch ein wenig skeptisch was die
tatsache betraf das tor ziehen schon
finanziert hat
eine davon überzeugt das gebäude zu
verkaufen
die erwartung einen termin im
sekretariat und unterbreitete per laster
und tara bassey einen vorschlag
ich habe mir schon mehr davon überzeugt
und das zu diesem preis er wäre bereit
das gebäude zu verkaufen
40 millionen pfund
das ist die summe auf die sich die
beiden italienisch englischen geldgeber
geeinigt haben und die taxi dem vatikan
überreicht eine beachtliche zahl die
nach ansicht der päpstlichen justiz
jeder rechtlichen und wirtschaftlichen
grundlage zu entbehren scheint
vor allem wenn man bedenkt dass das
sekretariat bereits 200 millionen dollar
in den fonds von raffaele millionen
gezahlt hatte und dass die immobilie mit
einem teil der kosten belastet war
tatsächlich gab der vatikan
363 millionen euro für ein gebäude aus
dass raffa element jona sechs jahre
zuvor für weniger als die hälfte dieser
summe erworben hatte
40 millionen sie kamen diese 40
millionen für mister minit zusammen
offensichtlich sind die 40 millionen
nicht auf initiative von herrn tor
zustande gekommen in dem sinne dass
natürlich auch das staatssekretariat ein
klares interesse an der
schadensminimierung gezeigt hat das
liegt auf der hand offensichtlich hat
herr missionen auf ein für ihn
sicherlich sehr wichtiges geschäft
verzichtet angesichts einer liquidation
die groß genug sein musste um das
staatssekretariat zurück in den besitz
der immobilie bringen zu können
waren sie etwas überrascht
sehen sie wir waren ein wenig überrascht
aber wissen sie wenn der kunde zufrieden
ist
ich war erstaunt darüber wie leicht es
war für etwas eine lösung in sechs bis
sieben tagen zu finden und das sich seit
dem 17 januar 2017 geplant hatte
maki aber wer ist die person die den
vatikan innerhalb weniger tage aus der
bredouille zu bringen schien
[Musik]
darüber haben wir noch nicht gesprochen
weil ich es selbst wissen wollte
sie war glücklich darüber er sagte nein
ich hatte einfach glück weil ich es
geschafft habe im kreise zu gelangen an
die ich nicht mal zu träumen gewagt
hätte
[Musik]
gianluigi wuchs im juli sie einer
kleinen stadt in mollis auf und besuchte
die schule für landwirtschaft
sein vater enrico hatte ein
getreidelager und stellte düngemittel
ihr familienunternehmen ja
und weil er es gewohnt war auf mehreren
hochzeiten zu tanzen gründete er zur
gleichen zeit ein weiteres unternehmen
im bereich wasseraufbereitung oder pizza
liebe was ist aus diesen beiden
unternehmen geworden
nichts beide sind bankrott gegangen
denn gianluigi hat um seine ziele zu
erreichen leider das leben seiner
familie für komplizierte und schulden
gemacht die dann zum bankrott führen
von düngemitteln zum tempel des herrn
durch verschiedene familiäre misserfolge
hindurch so begann gianluigi tores
karriere und führte ihn nach london
mitten ins herz der stadt
ist nicht der klassische italiener aus
einer kleinstadt der nach london geht
und dort zunächst einmal als
tellerwäscher anfängt nein er ging mit
einem unternehmen dorthin das bereit war
auf dem markt mitzumischen
[Musik]
einen solchen sprung von einer kleinen
stadt in police und von der produktion
von düngemitteln hin zur verwaltung
internationale fonds schafft man nicht
einfach nur weil man gut daran ist
wie ist er dort hingekommen juli ohne
sie ist das nervenzentrum der römisch
katholischen bewegung gemeinschaft und
befreiung in mollis
[Musik]
es gibt dort eine sehr starke
gemeinschaft höchstwahrscheinlich
ergaben sich die verbindungen zum
vatikan direkt aus der bewegung auch
weil einer der beteiligten der bewegung
sehr sehr nahe stand operation
[Musik]
der unternehmer aus police kommt also an
die schwelle des heiligen stuhls um den
streit um das londoner gebäude zu
schlichten doch zu diesem zeitpunkt war
dieser umstrittenen manager bereits
durch einen rechtlichen zwischenfall mit
verstörenden grundzügen in mollis
vorbelastet
[Musik]
wir sprechen von gianluigi nuzzi der uns
geschadet hat sagen wir mal betrogen um
das richtige wort zu benutzen
zunächst trat er an uns heran als freund
der helfen wollte der etwas tun wollten
kurz gesagt er entpuppte sich als judas
er hat uns eigentlich um alles betrogen
wir befinden uns in termoli police im
jahr 2010 hat die wirtschaftskrise die
familie war der messe an den rand der
wirtschaftlichen katastrophe getrieben
die geschäfte der kinder gehen in
konkurs und als sie in die enge
getrieben werden beschließen sie mit
gianluigi trovesi einen deal einzugehen
und ein touristendorf zu bauen sie
würden die familien villa am meer und
das land mitbringen der finanzier das
kapital
die villa hatte einen handels wert von
einer million und 2 1 millionen 300.000
euro
sie war alles ein spiel er sagte er
würde einen effektiven kaufvertrag auf
setzen indem wir den verkaufspreis der
immobilie auf 320.000 euro setzen so
würden wir auch weniger steuern zahlen
danach werden wir anfangen zu bauen und
alles so machen
und das wurde uns im grunde zum
verhängnis
die firma in der dieses familien juwel
gelandet ist ist eigentum von totti und
nicht von marcello korn acciona das dorf
hat keine baugenehmigung erhalten und
wurde nie gebaut so verlor die familie
war der nächste ihre schöne villa am
meer
von einem tag auf den anderen sahen wir
uns praktisch von unserem grundstück
verdrängt raus mit nichts einfach so wie
erstatteten anzeige bei der
finanzaufsicht ich habe ihnen gezeigt
dass sich auf schwindel herein gefallen
bin auf einen betrug der beamte drehte
sich um sah mich an und sagte theron
aktion sehen sie diesen stapel und er
zeigte mir einen stapel von aktenordnern
60 70 cm hoch auf einem schreibtisch das
sagte der beamte und sage mir dabei sehr
ernst in die augen ist alles von
gianluigi tozzi
[Musik]
seitdem fordert die familie
gerechtigkeit und sie ist nicht allein
in der tat gibt es viele offene
verfahren gegen den unternehmer einige
sogar vor seinem eintritt in den vatikan
gegenwärtig klagt die justiz ihn wegen
einer vielzahl von straftaten in rom
mailand bari und marino an nur im
dezember 2020 eine erste anhörung zu
einer angelegenheit stattfand die mit
der villa der familie war der nächste
verbunden war
[Musik]
stationen seine verbrechen reichen vom
besitz gestohlener güter bis zum
hausfriedensbruch und
dazu kommt noch die anstiftung zu
verbrechen
das haben sie dann irgendwann
beschlossen zu tun
ich bin plötzlich draufgekommen dem
papst zu schreiben und ihn kurz unsere
situation zu schildern
sie vorlesen was sie geschrieben haben
soll ich es vorlesen
[Musik]
sie kam genau zur richtigen zeit und wir
fanden uns in einer situation wieder in
der uns alles genommen wurde ohne dass
wir es merken denn alles wurde von einer
liebevollen fürsorge verschleiert eine
brüderliche hand bot uns an uns aus
einer schwerwiegenden wirtschaftlichen
lage zu befreien
[Musik]
mit der zeit wurde uns klar dass es eine
gelinde gesagt fragwürdige art war und
das grundstück in termoli zu entreißen
[Musik]
es ist der zweite weihnachtsfeiertag
2018 als etwas außergewöhnliches
passiert der papst gewerblichen luigi
torsi eine privataudienz
wir wissen nicht worüber sie gesprochen
haben aber sicher ist dieses treffen ist
zentral für das verständnis der weiteren
entwicklungen offenbar hat jemand der
dem papst sehr nahe steht ihm den
finanzier als retter des londoner
gebäudes vorgestellt
[Musik]
zu diesem zeitpunkt war er katholik
sowie hertha auch der den heiligen vater
besucht hat der für katholiken ja das
höchste religiöse oberhaupt der welt ist
ich kann ihnen sagen dass er sichtlich
bewegt war als er von der begegnung mit
dem heiligen vater erzählte
er sagte mir weißt du dass ich heute
nachmittag in den vatikan zum heiligen
vater gehen muss ich sagte glückwunsch
gut aber weißt du ich weiß nicht ob ich
gehen soll was soll das heißen du weisst
nicht ob du gehen sollst ich meine das
ist auch so eine schöne sache was sagst
du redest du mir zu gehen er ist
wirklich absurd
kann man also sagen dass herr todd sie
innerhalb des vatikans unantastbar
geworden war
nein sagen wir er hat ein problem gelöst
aber ein anderes geschaffen
tatsächlich ging das gebäude nicht
direkt von raffaele mission is at nah an
den vatikan sondern landete bei einer
firma namens dj luigi tosti gewürze
die vereinbarung sah vor dass das
staatssekretariat in der zwischenzeit
eine spezielle gesellschaft für das
londoner gebäude und dann für den makler
aus police gründen wird die aktien
verkaufen würde das geschah aber nicht
als sie diesen vertrag erhielten
stellten sie fest dass 1000 aktien der
stimmrechtsanteil betrug sie verbleiben
und ich wusste dass nicht einmal
die aktien mit stimmrecht genau der
vatikan konnte also nichts mit diesem
gebäude anfang ja sagen wir er war der
eigentümer aber verwaltet hat es wer
stimmberechtigt war wenn sie mich fragen
wenn er es am nächsten tag für 10.000
oder zehn millionen vor und hätte
verkaufen können hätte er das getan aber
war dem vatikan ihrer meinung nach klar
dass ja ein gebäude kaufte an dem er
keine rechte hatte
nein nein ich schließe das völlig aus
[Musik]
bei diesem treffen sagte totti ich werde
dafür sorgen dass sie das gebäude
zurückgehalten monsignore alaska ließ
ihn reden und nach einer weile sagte er
hören sie was bringen diese 1000 aktien
haben wir kein stimmen recht als sie ihn
larsen erkannten sie erst ich habe
diesen vertrag auch nie gesehen
ja wir sind auf dem weg
wir nehmen die nächste ausfahrt
im heiligen stuhl gibt es jedoch stimmen
die behaupten dass die bedingungen des
vertrages wohl bekannt waren dies wird
von einem hohen amtsträger des
kirchenstaates bestätigt bei einem
treffen zu stimmt allerdings unter der
bedingungen anonym zu bleiben
ja das ist er stelle es hier links von
ihm ab parke hier
der vertrag den sie mit kir
unterschrieben haben naja gibt keinen
sinn mehr macht keinen sinn ich habe ihn
gesehen
es stand schwarz auf weiß geschrieben
dass die aktien aller aktien mit
stimmrecht und ob sie gehen würden
während der heilige stuhl diejenigen
ohne stimmrecht bekam
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten entweder war
jemand so naiv oder sie waren böswillig
und haben viel geld dafür genommen
wenn man einen vertrag nicht verstehen
kann geht man zu einem anwalt richtig
sie haben einfach unterschrieben
es ist november 2008 als der neue
stellvertreter für allgemeine
angelegenheiten
monsignore edgar peña para der angelo
betta abgelöst hat die operation gut
heißt die sich in wenigen tagen als
kolossaler fehler erweisen wird
[Musik]
er hat also in der tat die volle
kontrolle über dieses gebäude obwohl er
keinen cent hineingesteckt hat als der
vatikan nach ein paar wochen beschließt
auch tut sie zu liquidieren sagt sie
aber ich habe diese anteile jetzt müssen
sie mir meine provision mit zahlen sonst
gebe ich diese anteile nicht zurück
diese aktien ermöglichten es sie in der
tat das gebäude unter seiner gewalt zu
haben und damit 200 millionen des
vatikans in seinen händen zu halten
wir kommen also zum epilog zum
verabscheuungswürdigen verbrechen das
von den richtern angenommen wurde die
erpressung des vatikans oder sie
verlangte vom heiligen stuhl zunächst
sogar 20 millionen euro um nach mühsamen
verhandlungen auf 15 millionen euro
runter zu gehen
ich glaube nicht dass diese zahlung das
ergebnis einer erpressung ist aber es
ist eine zahlung die offensichtlich mit
einem vorgang verbunden sein muss
die wahl bestand einerseits darin dem
sekretariat zu ermöglichen das eigentum
an der immobilie wieder zu erlangen und
andererseits ist der firma von herrn
tozzi durch 1000 stimmberechtigte aktien
zu ermöglichen diese immobilie fünf
jahre zu verwalten hertha hat man gesagt
er solle sich aus diesem geschäft
zurückziehen und deshalb sind 15
millionen vielleicht eine angemessene
entschädigung für das was man getan und
herrentorte offensichtlich in bezug auf
die verwaltung einer immobilie genommen
hat
in japan hatte mir anvertraut dass er
ein problem hatte weil sie sich aufgrund
dieses vertrages berechtigt fühlte 20
millionen zu verlangen um die aktien mit
stimmrecht zu verkaufen und das
unternehmen zu verlassen wenn japaner
kam zu mir um mir das mitzuteilen und
ich sage die mit einigem nachdruck
bezahlen sie ihn nicht bezahlen sie ihn
nicht
aber das staatssekretariat gärtner es
beginnt eine fieberhafte suche nach geld
bis monsignore per laster monsignore
peña barra eine lösung vorschlägt das
geld für die bezahlung von top- sie soll
von diskretion skonto des papstes
genommen werden ein konto das nur dem
heiligen vater zur verfügung steht das
entgegen jeder logik nicht beim br der
vatikanbank sondern bei einer schweizer
bank liegt
[Musik]
jung videochat chinese genau hier im
zentrum von lugano befindet sich das
büro eines tessiner treuhänders der dass
2015 bei der ubs eingerichtete
treuhandkonto des papstes verwaltet und
von diesem konto hätte der tessiner
treuhänder laut monsignore per laster 20
millionen pfund abheben müssen um die
forderungen von gianluigi tor zu
erfüllen
die anweisungen die nach lugano
geschickt wurden waren sehr präzise
zwölf millionen pfund sollten abgehoben
werden und es sollte ein
überziehungskredit von weiteren acht
millionen pfund beantragt werden
natürlich hätten wir den tessiner
treuhänder gerne getroffen aber aus
gründen der diskretion verweigerte er
ein interview
wir wissen also nicht ob das konto des
papstes betroffen sicher ist dass nach
angaben der justiz in jenen tagen 20
millionen euro auf einem konto der
vatikan anwälte in london eingegangen
sind und mit diesem geld wird gianluigi
bezahlt mit zwei überweisungen in höhe
von insgesamt 15 millionen euro
doch damit ist die geschichte noch nicht
zu ende die justiz vermutet dass dort
sie nicht allein gehandelt hat
ich habe der mann vollstes vertrauen
geschenkt weil du mir den arsch gerettet
hast aber habe ich will bezahlt werden
nicht gehen nicht einfach so gib mir
zehn millionen und ich gehe was zum
teufel soll ich dir sagen
[Musik]
es ist der 19 dezember 2018 die lage hat
sich verschlechtert und in einem hotel
in mailand verhält eine art
gipfeltreffen statt und sie davon zu
überzeugen die 1000 aktien zu verkaufen
aber die männer des vatikans traue
niemandem mehr und jemand zeichnet das
gespräch auf
selbst wenn sie mir zehn millionen geben
ich habe ihm eine million gezahlt was
denken sie er hat mich am abend vorher
angerufen ich habe die überweisung hier
ich erzähle kein scheiß verstehen sie er
rief mich am abend vorher an und sagte
das ist mein konto bei der ubs
was ist wirklich passiert er sagt
wörtlich gibt mir 8 millionen gibt mir
zehn millionen von denen ich drei übrig
habe weil ich die anderen mit
schmiergeldern gezahlt habe
glauben sie nicht dass das vielleicht
mal angeberei war
moment im eifer des gefechts wäre das
eine einfache möglichkeit ein einfacher
weg die situation aufzulösen klar ist es
gibt dafür keine beweise die
ermittler des vatikans versuchen
herauszufinden ob dieses geld komplett
und hat sie gehen oder auf ein teil
dieses geldes tatsächlich an beamte und
monsignore innerhalb des vatikans ging
deshalb versuchen sie herauszufinden ob
es intern korruption gibt die irgendwie
erklärt warum knebel verträge
abgeschlossen wurden zum nachteil des
vatikans und zum vorteil der weltlichen
geldgeber
es ist der 25 september 2020 als angelo
vecchio der vom skandal um das londoner
gebäude und eine reihe anderer
juristischer vorfälle überwältigt wurde
vom heiligen vater vorgeladen wird
der papst hat mir gesagt dass er mir
nicht mehr traut weil er einen bericht
von den richtern bekommen habe dass ich
gelder veruntreut haben soll ich habe
dem heiligen vater gesagt wenn er mir
nicht mehr vertraut gebe ich mein mandat
auf dann trete ich zurück das war's
mit dem motto
passt
seit gestern verzichtete kardinal auf
die mit dem amt verbundenen rechte und
wird nicht an der pontifex wahl
teilnehmen können ich fühle mich nicht
korrumpiert sagte er
die in dieser untersuchung vermuteten
verbrechen sind korruption veruntreuung
geldwäsche sogar erpressung und die
bildung einer kriminellen vereinigung
wurde sogar verhaftet und kam ins
vatikanische gefängnis
mit hilfe eines rechtshilfeersuchens an
die schweizer behörden forderte die
staatsanwaltschaft des heiligen stuhls
die herausgabe der bankverbindungen und
salden der konten von kardinal vecchio
monsignore pallaske fabrizio abassi
enrico klasse raffaele menschen die an
luigi taxi und vielen anderen dass in
ermangelung eines urteils gilt derzeit
für alle die unschuldsvermutung
es wird gegen sie ermittelt sie werden
beschuldigt mit hot sie kooperiert zu
haben aber ich denke wegen der
verschwörung gegen
erpressung erpressung und das ist es was
mich am meisten betrübt in dem
rechtshilfeersuchen werden sie als die
person genannt die am meisten von diesem
londoner bauvorhaben profitieren sollte
ja so verstehe ich es auch mit toll sie
und millionen
nein nein nein nicht im geringsten
für enrico gras so kommt der ärger nicht
nur aus dem vatikan auch in der schweiz
setzt den die justiz unter druck wegen
der geschäfte mit seinem centurion
investmentfonds in denen das
staatssekretariat rund 50 millionen euro
investiert hat eine weitere geschichte
die sich zu einer kriminalgeschichte im
vatikan entwickelt hat die dunkle zeiten
für den bankier gottes der nur noch auf
gerechtigkeit warten kann
es stimmt dass ich besorgt bin aber ich
habe keine angst ich habe mitleid mit
meinen kindern mit meinen enkelkindern
das ist etwas was ich nicht erwartet
habe ich hatte gehofft dass sie sich auf
andere weise an ihren großvater erinnern
würden nicht wegen dieses wirklich
unglaublichen unsinns wissen sie wie
sich das anfühlt es ist als würde man
mit einem menschen zusammenarbeiten ihm
helfen und dann dreht man sich
irgendwann um und wird hinterrücks
erstochen
so fühlt sich das an
satz
[Musik]